le chenal de shippagan est achalandé ce
matin les crabiers terminent leur saison
et ramènent avec eux leurs 150 casier
les bouger les cordages sont empilés sur
le pont à chaque sortie en mer le
capitaine stéphane ferrand on espère ne
pas voir de baleine noire dans ses
cordages de pêche en 2017 12 individus
ont péri dans le golfe du saint laurent
plusieurs empêtré dans des cordages de
pêche de toute évidence on fait partie
du problème
donc c'est juste logique qu'on fasse
partie de la solution
faut c'est trouver une façon coexister
avec les baleines
pour ce faire 15 crabiers semi
hauturiers comme le mic a role as we
frei ont été convertis en plateforme
scientifique
l'objectif développer des nouveaux
engins de pêche moins dommageable pour
la baleine noire
les baleines noires il reste environ 20
étant si ça continue au taux actuel au
taux de reproduction actuel autour de
mortalité actuelle la biologiste lyne
morissette chapeaute la mission selon
elle les fermetures de zones de pêche
imposés depuis trois ans par le
gouvernement canadien pour protéger les
baleines noires ne fonctionne pas et
baleines cette année elles sont pas du
tout dans la zone statique qu'on leur a
préparé pour les accueillir
donc ça marche pas ça marche pas on a
fermé nous ont présentement qui aurait
techniquement pu être pêchées coup on se
perd toute une communauté de pêcheurs
qui sont là on le voit le sont là avec
leurs idées leur volonté pour trouver
des solutions
scania bout et la baleine noire poussent
les pêcheurs à changer leur façon de
faire le mari caro a été équipée d'un
journal de bord électronique associée à
des capteurs attaché au bout et n'ont
jamais vraiment fait la partie
vers système intégré attendons ça va
envoyer un siège automatiquement auberge
heures sur
certains projets qui relevait de la
science fiction il n'ya pas longtemps
encore sont aujourd'hui mis à l'essai
l'idée du tennis et de pu avoir de coop
dans la colonne d'eau la colonne
verticale ou à ce que les baleines
baleine noire et plus à risque on
appelle ça le casier son cordage ou
cordages sur demande sont encore le
câblage le câblage et au fond de l'eau
donc il ya très peu de risque des
baleines s'empêtre la presse au club
la technique de pêche comme tu es là
pour beaucoup évolué
depuis les tout débuts c'est vraiment
savoir une petite révolution
il y a urgence d'agir le golfe du saint
laurent est un véritable labyrinthe pour
la baleine noire il y à 37000 cordages
en suspension seulement pour la pêche au
crabe des neiges les quasi sans cordage
s'impose donc dans les circonstances
comme la solution miracle c'est pas la
solution que ça prend pour que ça puisse
être adapté à bas la pêche commerciale
faut que le produit soit fonctionnel et
fonctionne à tous les coups
présentement c'est pour le corps la
simulation est réussie en piscine le
casier est remonté à la surface
on va vérifier à quelle place que le
ballon on a une minute c'est une toute
autre histoire en pleine mer 6 a
déclenché le rappelle moi tellement ça
veut pas sortir là on va essayer boire
c'est pour une question de matri deux
essais sont nécessaires pour que le
déclencheur ouvre le sac et déploie le
cordage est sortie ça prend 30 minutes
une éternité dans une journée normale où
le pêcheur de retrouver 150 casier la
belle utopie de penser que dans les
matins on va avoir dépassé sans cordage
parc où le la réalité sur les bateaux
c'est qu'il ya des enjeux à la dérive y
est les courants et les systèmes de
communication sont pas encore parfaits
les efforts déployés dans le golfe du
saint laurent sont colossaux mais
insuffisant lyne morissette et philippe
cornier rejoindre un autre capitaine
hockey de shippagan les pêcheurs côtiers
travaille aussi sur des nouveaux engins
de pêche une autre baleine noire a été
retrouvée morte une nouvelle presque à
tous les jours 8 carcasse depuis le
début de l'été la plupart dans le golfe
du saint laurent
plusieurs présentaient des traces dans
pétremand passé même si aucun individu a
succombé dans des cordages de pêche
les saisons passent et on dépend de nos
métiers pour éviter d'autres fermetures
de zones de pêche les krabi côtier
proposent eux aussi des mesures
d'atténuation on en train d'essayer de
voir s'il serait possible d'implémenter
une nouvelle façon de pêcher en natation
des trappes ensemble au fond de l'eau
qui diminuerait la quantité de cordage
ajouté plusieurs cases it crowd par
lignes de pêche pourrait diminuer de
moitié le cordage en suspension mais les
côtiers ont des plus petits bateaux avec
moins d espace
ce qui rend la manoeuvre périlleuse en
aluminium c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus léger raison pour laquelle
on remplace les casiers en faire par des
quasi en aluminium plus léger plus
faciles à manipuler à bord
c'est vrai qu'on sortait il faisait beau
moi j'ai une foi de nos pages régulière
de saison toujours beau
il sera là le vrai succès de la mission
scientifique
les prototypes devront non seulement
être fonctionnel facile et sécuritaire à
utiliser pour les pêcheurs mais aussi
rentable en parle
au-delà d'un million pour équiper un
bateau pas si on sait on parle d'eux
150 casier pour les pêcheurs
traditionnels
à court terme il est improbable que les
quasi sans cordage trop coûteux pas
assez fiables soient implantés les
pêcheurs proposeront des modifications
plus modestes comme des cordages faible
au maillon faible jusqu'à dix fois moins
solide qui pourrait céder plus
facilement lors d'un encadrement avec
une baleine noire
je vais pas baisser les bras tain qui va
rester une baleine noire dans le golf ou
dans l'atlantique nord il va toujours
rester une chance que
et le temps presse non seulement pour la
survie de la baleine noire mais aussi
pour la survie de toute une industrie à
partir de 2022 les etats-unis principaux
acheteurs de kraft canadiens pourront
interdire l'exportation de poissons et
de fruits de mer s'il considère que tous
les efforts n'ont pas été fait pour
prévenir l'extinction de la baleine
noire
[Musique]